true story several people were found
mysteriously murdered at a quaint
bed-and-breakfast and the murder weapon
was a crossbow did you bet this this is
absolutely real apparently the whole
thing was masterminded by a German man
who police believe was the leader of a
medieval SNM sex and murder cult this
has been a story that's caught a lot of
attention yes this is real now obviously
this story is troubling for tourists
planning to travel to Germany now
fortunately the German Board of tourism
quickly put together an ad addressing
this story take a look
perhaps you heard about Germany's recent
oopsie no not that one
or that one hmm no wrong again that's
bad but that's not it this one yeah that
was some bad news bears but don't let
that keep you from enjoying a German
vacation each region has its own beauty
and its own culture and not every German
isn't some crazy medieval crossbow
murder sex cult yeah some are in
steampunk crossbow murder sex thongs
others are members of kind of a moody
goth murder college where sex is totally
prohibited the kind on sort under this
verboten statistically fewer than 40
percent of Germans own a crossbow I like
those odds
still nervous to visit well look for the
sign outside all German hotels letting
you know this is a crossbow free zone
Germany name one bad thing that's ever
happened here you can't can you
see you soon
you